[Music]
do you want to have a little Redemption
right now no I don't ever want to do
that in Krista nation again you've won
an uncomfortable phone call to your ex
and the half-eaten hot dog from the back
of my car oh shut up RuPaul I'm not
gonna ask you to do a roof polymers oh
good I want to walk through your
all-stars three sisters and see if you
can do an impersonation of all of them
okay I can do a really good level of
crime that's the first one on the list I
feel like the judges are seeing
something that I'm not seeing she kind
of does that like vocal fry up and down
yeah everything is I feel like - she's
very non-confrontational I feel like I
don't think any of us are doing anything
new would Morgan McMichaels first to go
oh so bad I can't do a good Morgan he do
a naja oh this outfit this house that
mob adopted the poppet but I mean she's
just sounds she is sort of like growing
up instead of cereal she ate an episode
of drag race every day for breakfast and
that is what's coursing through her
veins is just like Bob and Eponine she
is I think she should be honorary House
of Edwards oh for sure he's walking
sound bites and splits
[Music]
torchy drag is fun whoo mustard whoo-oop
did you see that video that I just
posted up you guys should I'll send it
to you Dorji drinking about Oh chugging
a bottle of wine
thorgy i mean how much kicking do you
need to do she has some questionable
judgment but she's also white with
dreads so we knew that you should only
be thorgy if you're drunk
Kennedy Davenport Bob know that a ride
though that don't sit right my drag
right she is a hundred percent the most
lovable grumpy old man of drag I just
wasn't enthused and I'll she's like the
resting [ __ ] old man of beautiful
young woman drag that fared my chi chi
devayne chi chi devayne the by you
quaint everybody just sounds the same to
me I guess milk oh I don't know if I can
be that confident I know a lot of girls
think it's unfair for them to be going
home but shangela oh she is like to meet
I mean she's clearly like the narrator
of this season y'all told her on the
internet it was funny
I blame y'all and then a bebe Zahara
Benet oh I appreciate like a dramatic
shawl just like wrapped her on the hedge
it's like mother she loves to like enter
a room and like lay on a table with
sunglasses on it'd be like so how are we
feeling she is that Queen to that like
she were like while we're filming
she's like sensing what questions should
be asked next and then she like finds
her lightness like so who do you think
what do we think we're doing today who's
gonna be in the bottom
she is the gay feminine energy version
of James Earl Jones that sits right with
me yeah it's the circle of life sorry
[Music]